entendre les exigences du monde du
travail rencontre organisée hier par
ailleurs une campagne de terrain
essentiel pour les militants derrière
nathalie arthaud avec une présence
médiatique faible la candidate de lutte
ouvrière axe sa stratégie en allant à la
rencontre des citoyens ont fait la
campagne telle qu'on la conçoit c'est à
dire à la rencontre des gens à la fois
devant les gares sur les marchés comme
mon come on a commencé à faire comme on
fait tout le temps parce que de toute
façon les petits candidats on n'a pas
tellement le choix de faire cette
campagne proche de la population
si certains passants ne prête pas
attention tracts d'autres s'arrêtent et
échanges avec les militants en gros je
suis convaincu qu il faut comme vous le
faites convaincre le peuple d'abord et
pas prendre le peuple et lui dire tu es
toi sur notre système tu acceptes tu
sais bien de vendre du rêve au conte
citoyen français
mais d'un autre côté c'est aussi bien de
d'agir de la sorte c'est à dire le dire
les choses c'est une chose mais avec des
actes c'est encore mieux
j'ai senti que j'avais une discussion
possible
sur sur son programme en fait à des
signes de ça et comme chou c'est assez
rare finalement parce que là en ce
moment distribuer beaucoup de trac mais
sans forcément pas expliqué débattre en
fait coeur de l'électorat de lutte
ouvrière les travailleurs avec une
mesure phare pour les séduire
l'interdiction du licenciement